[Music]
on this tuesday night desperate times
call for desperate measures in quebec
with omicron spreading like wildfire the
province changes its rules to allow some
coveted positive essential workers to
remain on the job omicron's contingent
is so exponential we have no choice what
other provinces are doing to deal with
the surge
the new quarantine guidance in the u.s
shortening isolation time as states
report an explosion of cases
plus record-shattering cold in western
canada
how long the frigid temperatures are
expected to last
and to find the odds and making a splash
i'm so proud of him he came a long way
the transformative power of art for a
young boy with epilepsy
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
once again tonight with developments
related to the omicron variant across
canada case numbers are climbing like
never before today quebec set a new
record with more than 12 thousand new
infections in just 24 hours it's still
unclear whether the surge will lead to a
similar spike in hospitalizations though
quebec says the sheer number of cases is
already causing major strain the
province says about 7 000 health care
workers were off the job yesterday due
to covet the province is now making a
major change to rules for infected
workers to try to keep hospitals staffed
abigail beeman explains in tonight's top
story
we have no choice in the face of another
record number of cases and thousands of
health care staff off the job quebec
makes a controversial move allowing some
essential staff who test positive to
work there is people who really have
some symptoms very soft ones
who can go work again and they feel okay
they could go in certain units where
there's already covered people positive
details aren't all clear unions are
worried about their members and the
public and now we're asking them on top
of giving your 110 normally now you
gotta have you have to come in sick and
do your job
it's for us it makes absolutely no sense
a balancing act for a province and
country full of exhausted health care
staff we're so much more tired
because we we haven't had new people
come in and
that's why the morale is low that's why
it's difficult no such move in ontario
but the top doctor there is now
considering new cdc guidance cutting
isolation periods in half in long-term
care where 41 homes have outbreaks new
restrictions as of thursday all general
visits to long-term care homes will be
paused the latest data from the ontario
science table shows while two doses of
vaccine still offer very high protection
against hospitalization your protection
against infection is comparable to those
who haven't been vaccinated at all right
now dr peter uni says the next eight
weeks will be tough but then things will
change nearly everybody here in ontario
and in canada will be
immune at least partially either through
vaccination or through infection in the
short term parents are anxious for news
about school they'll be having an
announcement in the next couple days
but we're just want to see how things go
while nova scotia says school will start
a week late but kids will be in class
having kids in school is the best
decision to minimize overall harms to
children and youth abigail demon global
news ottawa
at the world juniors in alberta team usa
forfeited a game against switzerland
today after two players tested positive
for covet 19. the international ice
hockey federation says the defending
champions are under team quarantine the
federation says a decision will be made
later on whether the u.s can place
sweden tomorrow
in the u.s the omicron variant is
spreading like wildfire testing sites
are swamped hospitalizations are up and
now the center for disease control has
cut quarantine guidelines in half for
positive asymptomatic patients it comes
as airline and healthcare worker
shortages grow jennifer johnson has the
latest
as more and more healthcare and airline
workers are sidelined by coven 19 the
centers for disease control made a
surprising announcement reducing the
quarantine period for positive but
asymptomatic patients from 10 to 5 days
if you look at the chance of getting a
transmission in that second half of that
10-day period it's considerably less
than in those first few days but the cdc
strongly recommends mask wearing from
days 5 to 10.
the agency has been getting heat from
airlines who have been forced to cancel
thousands of flights over the holiday
due to staff shortages about four
o'clock in the morning and uh got to the
airport got on the plane everything was
fine and then one of the pilots didn't
show up
travel experts say the post-christmas
chaos at airports will continue through
the new year airlines are taking drastic
measures cutting dozens of routes they
pulled out of a number of cities
americans pulled out of 26 cities delta
and united about 10 cities each now
hospitalizations of children are
drastically increasing too up 35 percent
from last week new york city has seen a
five-fold increase in pediatric
admissions this month desperate to stop
the spread the mayor is now offering 100
incentives for people who get the
booster shot we talked about every day
we've seen a huge uptick new daily cases
in the u.s are now surpassing 180 000 a
day we've moved backwards it's really
disheartening to see that this many
months if not years later in the
pandemic with many testing sites and
pharmacies out of cobit 19 tests u.s
president joe biden is promising states
federal help i know the lines have
gotten very long in some states that's
why i ordered fema to set up pop-up
sites in places with high demand the
president is also planning to use funds
from the defense production act usually
set aside for wars to produce 500
million rapid at-home test kits as
america wages its latest battle against
this virus
jennifer johnson global news washington
today in the uk another daily record for
new covet 19 cases with more than 129
thousand it comes as scotland and other
places in the uk tighten restrictions to
try to reduce the spread of omicron but
not in england prime minister boris
johnson says no rules will change before
the new year redmond shannon reports
it's estimated 1.7 million people in the
uk had covert 19 last week forcing manny
to pair back holiday celebrations
we try to be sensible and
both protect ourselves and each other
now nightclubs in scotland wales and
northern ireland have closed and other
hospitality venues face new restrictions
but in england the rules are more lacks
and will stay that way for now
there will be no further measures uh
before the new year
we won't be taking any further measures
of course people should remain cautious
as we approach new year celebrations for
much of the pandemic rules in england
have been looser than in the other uk
nations or they began later get that jab
prime minister boris johnson's
government is betting on boosters and on
the early evidence that omicron is less
severe that's good news but we know that
it spreads very rapidly so we have to
set that news against that and many of
those on the front lines of healthcare
are worried that allowing a free-for-all
on new year's is a big risk the view is
very clear it's still too early to tell
about whether we are going to see larger
numbers of older people coming in
needing that kind of care
part of the reason for england's
divergence may be that johnson is a
leader under pressure from the
libertarian side of his own party those
mps have rebelled during votes on other
covet rules comparing england's
situation to the rest of the uk one
month from now will determine if johnson
made the right call and may help us all
better understand omigron redmond
shannon global news
the bitter cold snap gripping western
canada isn't letting up just yet and
organizations caring for vulnerable
people say it's taking a serious toll
the things that we're seeing come
through the door is extreme frostbite
and uh lack of you know lack of
appropriate outerwear things like that
so um
yeah a lot of people coming in crying a
lot because it hurts so much of course
when your feet start to unthaw
weather warnings are in place for much
of the west virtually all of alberta is
under an extreme cold alert as well as
most of saskatchewan and bc the alberta
motor association says it's dealing with
an 800 percent increase in calls for
roadside assistance this morning in
edmonton the estimated wait time for a
tow was more than three days
so how much longer will this extreme
cold last let's bring in chief
meteorologist anthony farnell now
anthony what can we expect over the next
few days
colleen it's going to be a few days but
there's already signs that conditions
are improving especially for bc into
alberta the temperatures still frigid
but it's not quite as windy the heart of
the cold has been in saskatchewan that's
now moving into manitoba minus 21 after
yesterday's snow in winnipeg it's only
going to get colder for the next couple
of days and when you factor in the wind
still some areas close to -40 wind chill
at night that drops to near minus 50.
let's talk about the good news
temperatures in alberta 12 degrees
warmer today right now in calgary than
it was yesterday edmonton also milder
same thing with vancouver five degrees
warmer than on monday what's causing
this crazy record cold well we have this
ridge just off the west coast bringing
warmth to alaska that's allowed siberian
air to make its way into western canada
that's now been cut off but the cold has
nowhere to go so it's going to take some
time to slowly moderate as we move
through and into the new year
colleen
thanks anthony
a year of reckoning coming up the
necessary work ahead for canada in the
name of truth and
reconciliation 2021 was a year of
reckoning for canada in may 215 unmarked
graves were discovered near the site of
a former residential school in kamloops
and more discoveries across the country
followed it forced non-indigenous
canadians to take a hard look at the
horrific treatment of indigenous
children and present-day injustices to
indigenous peoples and while there has
been some change the work is far from
done here's heather your ex west
it was news that shocked and rattled the
world
215 unmarked graves many belonging to
children found near the site of a
residential school in kamloops british
columbia
for anyone unfamiliar with the country's
history of taking indigenous children by
force from their families to be
assimilated in church-run institutions
the revelation was a horrific surprise
but for survivors hearing that children
were found buried there
only confirmed things long known they
would scoot us from the dormitory
to the church
don't mind the graves don't mind the
grave and just walk by
bernard jack has carried the trauma of
his time at the christie roman catholic
residential school on vancouver island
for over five decades he was a
six-year-old boy when he was first taken
from his mom and dad we were
basically dumped at the wharf where
priests and nuns were waiting for us
the really bad bedwetters
were tied to the top of the bunk
and strapped
literally strapped
and you could just hear their screams to
cover up the other screams jack says
2021 has been a year of painful
remembering but validation too
because at last non-indigenous canadians
and people around the world
are finally confronting the truth
this year saw canada mark the first ever
national day for truth and
reconciliation on september 30th a day
to be observed annually so all canadians
can stop and reflect people had heard
the information before
but i think seeing the physical evidence
of it
was
very difficult for people to turn away
from
and it allowed them to question more
about what is going on today
because although canada's last
residential school closed in the 1990s
thousands of indigenous kids are still
being taken from their families
only now it's through the child welfare
system instead before i think that there
was um really a white noise barrier
between residential schools and the
contemporary injustices i think slowly
thanks to the those discoveries that's
starting to be pierced through earlier
this year a federal court upheld an
order by the canadian human rights
tribunal that ottawa pay compensation to
first nations children's families who
have been harmed by the government's
underfunding of child and family
services on reserve
this month the federal government
announced 40 billion dollars was being
set aside to be spent not only
compensating families but fixing a
broken system too negotiations on a deal
with indigenous child welfare advocates
still continue with the deadline of
december 31st this is 30 years of the
cost of failure and that cost is high
there will be more work to do to achieve
reconciliation with the canadian
government but there are also calls for
greater truth and transparency from the
catholic churches who operated
residential schools
next year an indigenous delegation will
head to the vatican to meet with the
head of the catholic church their
planned visit was cancelled because of
covet this month
pope francis has agreed to come to
canada as well we have the opportunity
to have the tone start at the top
meaning the pope of the church
to come to canada and set the tone with
an apology
the cowas first nation is working to
identify more than 750 unmarked graves
identified last summer near the maryvale
residential school
chief cadmus delorme says that saying
sorry must only be the start of the
church's work
moving forward the church needs to be a
partner in reconciliation if it doesn't
happen like that
i do see in 50 years
we're going to hand this off to the next
generation to figure out it's like
for instance
if he was driving a bus for 26 people
kids in there and crash
that all the kids die and he survives it
oh i'm sorry
that doesn't mean anything
for bernard jack the residential school
system changed his life
it destroyed the lives of many around
him and continues to impact his children
and grandchildren's lives today
generational trauma can extend hurt
through families for decades
jack says a papal apology alone is not
justice in his mind
but every step towards the truth
that's at least a good place to begin
heather yorks west global news calgary
ahead fixing your finances tips for
making resolutions and keeping yourself
on track
you're watching global national
it's the season for new year's
resolutions and according to ipsos
polling exclusively for global news
nearly half of us plan to make a big
effort to do things differently in 2022
many of those new year's goals are about
money and gaviola has more on how to
stick to your finance related
resolutions
whether it's getting into better shape
or choosing healthier options the new
year may seem like the perfect time to
commit to new goals in the new year
you're able to
have a fresh perspective according to
ipsos polling for global news 41 said
they plan to make new year's resolutions
of those people 48 aim to pay off debt
45 want to make and stick to a budget 36
percent want to save for a rainy day and
34 say they want to save money for
retirement and invest in 2022.
you've heard of dry january right well
instead of cutting out booze personal
finance author melissa leong plans to
spend only on necessities for at least
21 days in january her advice for
sticking to a money-related resolution
be clear about why you're saving for
example people who
put money into envelopes labeled with
their children's names were less likely
to dip into those envelopes because it
had a greater meaning for them and if
you can automate savings so the money
comes right out of your account then
you're more likely to stick to your
goals a lot of people put savings at the
bottom of their personal finance plan so
they spend on their bills first then
they spend on their wants next and then
they you know save whatever's left over
flip that around start saving first when
it comes to deciding what your targets
are be specific and realistic you can
say to yourself by december 31
2022 i would just save three thousand
dollars and i will do so by setting
aside money
every single paycheck
it's just as simple as that rather than
saying i want to save start building
those habits that might last throughout
then the year in a month's time so every
time you want to make a purchase say for
example more than a hundred dollars say
i'm gonna spend 24 hours thinking about
this purchase before i actually make it
once you're clear on your goals find an
accountability partner and schedule
check-ins to keep you on track if you
don't feel comfortable choosing a friend
or family member you can find an online
community just for this studies show
that when you have an accountability
partner people with peer support
actually save more money even if that
conversation was through text than those
who did not one final piece of advice
even if you follow all of these steps
life happens and you could get derailed
go easy on yourself if your 2022 plans
are delayed and become part of your
financial resolutions for 2023 ann
gaviola global news toronto
next therapy through art how the
pandemic helped uncover a new passion
for a toronto boy with epilepsy
we don't have to remind you how
difficult and dark these last few years
have felt but if you've thrown yourself
into a creative project during the
pandemic you know how powerful it can be
karen lieberman has the story of how
painting has changed the life of one
toronto boy
blue and orange and yellow angry
alessandro rizzotti wants to be an
artist when he grows up his mother says
the fact that he can even articulate
that is a miracle
good job we always say he's a warrior
and a fighter alessandro is only seven
but his medical history is long he
survived neonatal meningitis followed by
a stroke and he's had two brain
surgeries he also had infantile spasm
which is a very rare type of seizures
from there
he developed epilepsy
and right now he's dealing with adhd
and global delay
doctors weren't sure alessandro would
ever walk or talk
that's how you do that i'm so proud of
him he came a long way
uh you know he still takes therapies and
um and i went to the lego show okay
you see the gold that's kind of like
so you see venus and you see the earth
and most mars is there
he has plenty to say mostly about his
art
neptune when the pandemic began life in
lockdown was difficult for this family
when we were stuck at home it was very
hard
so you know i had to think of things and
and then school on top of that we were
doing school from home painting became
alessandro's passion
i'm gonna be on tv i think uh we found
his hidden talent he actually sold few
as a request i i shipped few paintings
to us to new york and texas
his latest creation a painting to be
auctioned off for sickkids hospital a
way to give back alessandro also
fundraises for epilepsy toronto it means
that we can continue to give the support
that we gave to that family to many
other families and that's and many other
people one in 100 people live with
epilepsy that's over 40 000 people in
the toronto area for alessandro creating
unique artwork is therapeutic
karen lieberman global news toronto
beautiful alessandro and that is global
national for this tuesday i'm colleen
christie tonight's your canada is this
festive scene at butchart gardens in
brentwood bay bc a place i know well
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and i hope to see
you here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves good night
[Music]